okay I think I've got this sorted
maybe all right I'm gonna keep fiddling
with this and I hope that the ridiculous
way I have that rigged up doesn't
completely fall over Oh someday someday
this will not be an absolutely mess of
me
fiddling with the camera for the first
chunk of it someday but not today Hey
oh boy yeah the lighting is is killing
me for put this set up hang on let me
try something
this is it's gonna be this for the
opening bit sorry in advance that's
that's really dark oh goodness that set
better ah that's gonna have to do hey
everybody this has been this has been a
bit of a day for me hello from Britain
hello to you it's been a long time well
it's been about two weeks mm-hmm excuse
me
so yes um happy Pride Month there's no
it was missing something
there we go I couldn't figure out why I
felt naked for a second mm-hmm um so
yeah I I really went back and forth on a
theme for this one and because like
there's just so much oh thank you thank
you that actually care when my mind gave
me this the the lighting in here sucks
so you can't quite tell but it it is it
is full rainbow it is a it is a pride
bandit
but you know with with everything going
on I didn't know if having it be Pride
themed felt like it was diverting
attention from things that needed it
more and I don't I didn't know but I
also didn't know how much I should be
talking about other stuff because you
know I said previously - not the voice
to be listening to look a lot of these
things but I'm just gonna wing it it's
the best I can do I just got my new
eyeglasses that have rainbows on the
edges of the frames ooh love it
hey there Cara from Ireland yes I know
and I love it
love the bow I may not be a member of
the LGBTQ community but happy Pride
Month
thank you I'm watching on two devices
one of you must be a ganger but which
one you should be respectful above your
bandana so pretty so your glasses thank
you very much so yeah with with
everything that go that is going on and
honestly particularly and right now in
regards to just even LGBTQ stuff it's
been it's been a bit of a roller coaster
in just the last week or so of all
seasons of sheer on princesses of power
which one do you think was the best
written probably season 5 like I just
admire the writing on that from being
able to wrap everything up as well as
they did but you know even just looking
specifically at the lgbtq+
things for at least for the moment
you know we had back-to-back the Trump
administration finalizing its update to
guidelines which allows for the denial
of medical services to to trans people
which
you know the the whole thing they are
it's funny I I told that to my mother um
you know who's a nurse her entire
working life she was a nurse and her
immediate thought was why would any
medical professional ever do that
because in her view that should never
even be a consideration that a medical
professional would deny treatment or
care to somebody for any reason much
less for that reason so but the thing is
that as much of that sucked that wasn't
news to me like he's been signaling that
he was gonna do this for two years and
it seemed it seemed like the
finalization of it caught a lot of
people off-guard
a month ago they signaled that they were
planning to still go through this in the
middle of a pandemic when a lot of
people are needing health care hmm nice
timing so you know I I knew when I sort
of had my I just did my morning on that
issue a while back but I know I know a
lot of trans people who you know didn't
realize that the finalization was coming
down right now and so I know that hit a
lot of people hard but then Oh
almost immediately after we have the the
ruling from the Supreme Court which is
such an important ruling like let's be
really clear about something it does not
suddenly mean that trans and LGBTQ plus
people of all stripes are suddenly all
set and care for and they're protected
and we did it yeah well no no it's only
specifically in the areas of jobs and
it's now not legal to discriminate
against people who are non heterosexual
or non cisgender whatever variants they
may be in either area to be
either rejected from a job or dismissed
from a job because of those facts about
them it doesn't mean it won't still
happen this is something that I talked
about a couple years ago on the very
wild channel just because there are
reasons they're not allowed to do it
doesn't mean they won't plenty of
businesses will still discriminate on
that basis the thing is it's actually
incredibly hard to prove discrimination
because you basically need a paper trail
proving that the reason you were fired
was a reason that they're not allowed to
fire you for so just using myself if the
people at my job the people in charge of
deciding whether or not I stay there
decided that they didn't want me there
they can't just call me into the office
and say well you're clearly non gender
conforming we don't know what's going on
we don't like it pack your bags like
that they can't do what they can do is
bill is see see you like go through
everything I've ever done
to see if anything I've ever I've ever
done is a dismissable offense see if has
been overlooked in the past they can
make adjustments to the expectation so
that I'm no longer meeting them so I can
be so I could be dismissed on failing to
do the job correctly
um basis they can simply eliminate my
job like if they cut the position and
don't hire for it again that's not a
firing that's downsizing that's
completely different so the simple fact
is and and my daughter's mother was an
HR so I know all the inside tricks on
this if they want to get rid of you
because you're trans or gay they will
they just won't say that that's the
reason they're doing it unless they're
incredibly stupid not none of that is to
undermine the importance of this ruling
because these kinds of basic protection
if those aren't even there trying to
push for any further progress is so hard
because you're standing on virtually no
foundation we have much stronger
foundation to stand on now it's and
that's a big deal a whole bunch of
comments have come through plus a super
jet so I'm gonna try and catch up real
quick
let's see had it a second ago if the
doctor generated into a chicken nugget
would their companion be ketchup or
barbecue sauce well it depends on
whether you want an ideal companion
pairing or an adversarial companion
pairing depends on what kind of thing
you're going for doesn't it
I wouldn't pair them with barbecue
though if you would be any Doctor Who
character you'd be Strax mainly because
you've gender spliced yourself for all
nursing needs well I am capable of
providing immense quantities of
lactation or fluid I think that grabs
probably gonna get me demonetised out
but I couldn't
oh that makes me happy the guy playing
the villain in corona virus virus us was
hammy seem to be doing a weird voice to
try and make his dialogue sound more
natural but I also heard he was from
Kenya so I should probably explain that
comment so the video went up today on
Stu bag full channel if if you don't
subscribe to him already you should he's
great and amazing and hilarious and
delightfully dark he a year two years
ago he did this thing talking about
brexit where he talked about it as if it
was a TV show and he talked about you
know how they the writers seem to have
lost the threat of where they were going
in their replacing all these characters
all the time and who the heck is this
person and oh maybe they're gonna fake
no they're just gonna
this out and he did something similar
with coronavirus that video went out
today and I do feature and that briefly
cuz he talks about the UK series
coronavirus and I talk about the
American version which true to American
remakes by their nature is grandeur and
scale and much much dumber so that is up
today that's what that comment was in
reference to and I would recommend you
check that thing out because it's
hilarious let's see a friend of mine is
studying to be a nurse and said he has
classmates who ask what if we don't
agree with their lifestyle and the
professor says find a new profession yes
to that professor like for God's sake
which is the best which is the better
band in your opinion Radiohead or Oasis
I only know a couple of songs from
either one of them so I don't know sorry
I'm a bad person to ask about music
preferences because first of all my
tastes are all over the place and I'm
like not versed like there's so many
things to people like oh you heard this
like I don't know what that is I get the
looks of her that happens to be a lot um
weird question
they don't worry you're at home you're
you're home here but I'm from UK we
don't pay for our medical care in
America you do how much does it cost if
you were to go to the hospital
eg you broke your arm well so I shall
attempt to briefly summarize a very
complicated and broken medical system so
we don't have universal health care in
America what we have is we have an
insurance situation where if you need
any medical treatment of any kind you
are either paying for the entire cost
completely out of pocket which I'll come
back to that or you're paying for it
through your insurance which usually
means you have okay there's all sorts of
things there's deductibles dues premiums
basically insurance is a way
you pay some amount for your care but
your insurance company picks up the rest
of it and what your insurance cost run
will vary because not all insurers will
cover all procedures and some they'll
cover more fully than others so even
that is a hodgepodge but just generally
speaking if you have insurance then that
is picking up some of your medical costs
the vast majority of Americans have
insurance through their job
which as we as the point is being made
right now as so many people are out of
work due to coronavirus having your
ability to be able to get health care
tied to the fact that you're employed is
actually really kind of stupid it is
possible to get health insurance outside
of being employed but it is more
expensive to do so getting insurance
through your employer is much more
affordable so if you go to the hospital
and you don't have insurance then you
have to pay out of pocket for everything
if you need to take an ambulance you
have to pay for that if you are admitted
to the emergency room that is that cost
right there before anyone even sees you
before there are even procedures or
anything else done these costs add up
really really quick to the tune of tens
of thousands of dollars for something as
simple as a broken bone part of the
reason for that is actually the fault of
the insurance scheme that we have
because trying to think of a way to
explain this prices are jacked up
because insurance has deeper pockets
than consumers do so the prices for all
these procedures are actually jacked up
quite high now insurance companies will
actually negotiate with hospitals to
bring them a little bit lower that's a
whole other thing that I don't know a
ton about but that starting level that
on paper what the procedure costs is
intentionally jacked up to either give
bargaining power against the the insurer
company or to actually dig into their
deep pockets because insurance companies
can afford a lot more but because you
are not allowed to you know outside of
contracts that are signed and things
like that just simply offer someone the
same thing at a different price than
someone else because that's price-fixing
if you go in as a person without
insurance you are paying that top-line
price the unknit not covered by
insurance intentionally jacked up price
like I said tens of thousands is really
typical I when we lived in New York I
had I had one occasion I don't want to
talk about those circumstances but I had
one occasion in which I ended up having
to pay for a ambulance trip that was not
covered by our by the insurance needed
an ambulance and it wasn't covered that
ambulance that ride in the ambulance to
the hospital which was less than a mile
away was $3,000 so there you go it's
broken the system is very very very very
very very very broken thank you for your
openness Bob first of all thank you not
nightmares mm-hmm um that's incredibly
generous so thank you right off the bat
part of the reason I'm out
with two of my friends Oh is my openness
whoa totes thank you I figured out last
month I'm LGBTQ basically by gender
confusion but you know I don't know
probably not proper terms but I'm me and
totes strange see here's the thing just
realizing that you're not straight and
or cisgender that's a starting point you
don't have to be out what you are yet
you figured out well I'm not this now
you can start exploring and figuring out
what you
and with any luck that'll be a wonderful
journey I hope it is for you I really
really really do if I'm correct there's
an or there's an electrical I lost it
back about lots of questions that I have
fallen so far back on cuz I've uh I've
gone on long rambles here if I'm correct
there's an election in the US this
November it I say if Trump gets voted
out that would be great way to end
what's otherwise been a really crappy
year
I mean look given just I mean he'll look
at me it shouldn't be a huge shock that
I am NOT a Trump fan but the thing is
getting him out while important that and
it would be a nice note you know it's a
big part of things like black lives
matter and why and why have now kind of
gone off on health care and on the the
Supreme Court ruling is that these
problems are systemic they are baked
into the system and while Trump has
exacerbated virtually every problem that
this nation already had the problems
were still pre-existing there's lots of
things that as a society as a nation we
have either failed to account for or
have just let go unaddressed and some of
those things it's not just a matter of
people aren't being assisted people are
being actively harmed and we've let
these systems in place for a long long
long time these are systems that a lot
of us benefit some way from as a white
person I benefit from systemic racism
and that's something I'm working through
because it hey it has to change its yeah
I've graduated college with an
associate's degree in communication and
a minor in writing Oh congratulations
Connor I wasn't completely distracting
you whenever you were you are all the
lifestream doing homework great that's
wonderful to hear
imagine the master dr. oh jeez I think
this year's pride makes it five years
for me to be out of the closet oh that's
nice
oh I never know how to gauge how long
I've been out of the closet because I
don't know I don't know what date to go
by because there was you know when I
first came out to anybody
there's when I came out to my mother
there's when I came out to close friends
there's when I came out publicly on this
channel there's when I came out on all
other social media there's when I I
still haven't really come out at work
but I've stopped presenting as cisgender
at work like and these are all different
days some of them years apart be nice to
have like one date to be able to
celebrate as an anniversary
I love how Reilly's wife in Buffy is
practically a strimmer given how the
other characters act around her Oh God
I've not seen that episode forever I
barely remember her huh I look away for
one second and you grab your boob that's
what you get for not paying attention I
had this idea that somewhere in the past
there must have been a doctor who was
only the doctor for all of five minutes
it could be a fun one off episode well
they did that it was it was called curse
of the fatal death and granted it was
done for comedy but steer but
still it still huh sad thing is I am
only drinking water
ah
do you watch Sailor Moon I call like a
couple of episodes like back in the 90s
but no do you miss vine I kind of do
yeah I did like mine
I missed tumblr too it's technically
still around but like let's be honest it
ain't the same it's not as much fun
thank you very much randomness no one
talks about brings it anymore thanks to
corona well that's the kind of the thing
like all these things they keep drowning
out things that are still problems but
haven't gone away because something
bigger came or either bigger or more
immediate you know we were all talking
about the wildfires in Australia and
then we had coronavirus and we had
murder Hornets for a hot second then
people got over that and then we then in
the US we have the resurgence of black
lives matter in the wake of more further
truly atrocious events from the police
and and I know like things kicked off
with George Floyd but I don't it's not
like we had known about the problem for
George Floyd and it's not like there
weren't other things that are already
gone on Brianna Taylor was weeks maybe
even a month before him and and so many
people yeah and then yeah and then that
became the big news because the the
police decided the best way to handle
protests against police brutality was to
unleash brutal tactics on protesters
yeah that makes sense so now that's the
news but of course Corona hasn't gone
away the murder Hornets haven't gone
away
like the new cycle changes what the news
is talking about change is both just
because they stopped talking about
something
doesn't mean it's gone which is the
depressing thing after re-watching
Shiraz season 3 I caught that mica in
the alternate reality right before he
disappeared tried to tell Angela he was
still alive in the main reality that
hurt yeah like I I had caught that but I
hadn't been prepared to believe that
that that was what he was saying but I
did know some people you know early on
claiming that that was but that was what
he was trying to say so yeah but today
if you're catching that for the first
time that's kind of cool is Chris
Chibnall the George Lucas or the Rian
Johnson of Doctor Who neither he's the
Chris Chibnall of Doctor Who we don't
have to compare to everything look I
don't think anyone is capable of being
the George Lucas and you you can't be
the George Lucas of something if it
predates your involvement like the
reason George Lucas is the George Lucas
of Star Wars is because he created it
nobody ever would have let anybody other
than the original creator of this stuff
do what he did with Star Wars like let's
be honest about that and compared to
Rian Johnson doesn't seem right either
just because I'm gonna do a video about
this at some point talking about Rian
Johnson's whole body of work because
what Rian Johnson is by his nature so
far as I can tell is a deconstructionist
and as much as Chibnall is shaking up
especially in this last series Doctor
Who like it or not he's doing some bold
stuff none of this particularly
deconstructionist it's not forcing you
to alter your like a retcon is not the
same as a deconstruction
he's retconning all to heck but he's not
deconstructing the work the show the
genre so and neither comparison holds up
chicken run is turning 20 tomorrow I saw
that in the theaters and now I feel old
what are your favorite bands in acts I'm
also really all over the place with
music tastes um
weird al' pink I like Lindsey sterling a
lot I was on Blind Guardian for a while
it kind of eased off then they started
to get back into their power metal roots
and I'm like yeah pass those I think
those are the ones that I liked and
followed the longest even if I dropped
off jaws is turning 45 on Sunday Oh
we'll see that's fine cuz that's older
than I am
although I have seen jaws in a movie
theater it's what it was one of those
sort of boutique theaters that shows
older movies I went inside job
and that was actually a lot of fun
because jaws is a movie that I know so
well I know I can I have it memorized I
could recite the whole dang thing for
you but the audience some of them either
had never seen at all but and a bunch of
the rest of them clearly hadn't seen in
a long time so I knew when the jump
scares were coming I just got to sit
back where's the entire audience
collectively blah oh that's great oh
that's so much fun did some publicity
work for you mention Council of geeks on
a live stream for Kim Nano sounds
Richards of the yogscast check and check
in the mail we'll see if it pans out and
that and then yes we can we can talk
about a promotional feed do you have
Disney Plus I do not I am really trying
to keep my my expenses down these days
three grand for a bloody ambulance yeah
I know right
boy that's how far back I am jeez Buffy
is the timeless child of God let me
explain she starts as the one then
another gets the power through her and
finally the power is given to all the
others that could get it maybe and I
know you I know you're only fighting
that too to get a rise out of me I I see
you I know what you're doing it's fine
because it's good-natured but huh
oh god I'm so far behind holy cow
I might have to I might have to jump
further down and give up on trying to
catch up on questions for me it's a case
of not really feeling gender at all but
not having any need to change my default
presentation valid completely valid um
you're not the first person I've ever
heard say that either
so valid and you're not the only one so
I just hit 1,000 on insta woo very cool
thank you um I'm at like 1500 on the
bear wild Instagram I can't remember
what the council of geeks Instagram is I
update it very sporadically also
identifying as straight feels wrong when
dating a non-binary person yeah that's
that's that's a tricky thing and that's
something that I myself don't always
know how to parse well the question
comes up for me like are you gay or are
you straight like well you're talking to
someone with a fluid sense of gender so
you know that that's some of the
problems with the language that we use
the terms gay and straight not only
describe who you are attracted to but
also who you are because straight means
attracted to the just forgive the
outdated language on this role with me
attracted to the opposing gender and gay
means to try to do the same gender but
you have to know what gender you are for
either of those terms to have any
meaning so if you either have a
fluctuating sense of gender which I do
or you have a sense of gender that
doesn't fit the binary where there are
clear and opposing genders for you to
say you're either the same or the
opposite to then the terms gay and
straight kind of break down a bit so
yeah that's the problem that I have like
I tend for me I tend to leave it at my
partner's a woman so whether that means
you consider me straight or pansexual or
bi I mean like I actually usually say
pansexual because even though my
attractions have
lean feminine or feminine presenting yes
that includes trans women trans women
are women um I do have a chart since I
can go other ways but you know so for me
I guess in a way I'm fortunate because I
I can I can take the term pansexual
which does not have to confirm my own
sense of gender in order to be used but
if that's not the case for you if you
have clearer attractions then yeah the
language falls apart you don't do fan
theories but here's one for black mirror
okay metalhead in 15 million marriage
take place at the same time the robot
dogs are hunting people who rejected
that society um I mean maybe I wouldn't
feel the need to connect the dots on any
of those but yeah as a head Canon it
works sure not essential shops finally
reopening here in the UK so yesterday
bought the office Elementary 30 rock I
Met Your Mother and first three seasons
of the good place well you are all set
for a bit now aren't you Rowan okay so
imagine that classic who companion meets
a new who companion who would you want I
feel like ace meeting bill would be
called that would be cool I mean my
immediate default is Jamie and Donna
just because you know favorite classic
companion favorite new who companion so
that's that's where my brain immediately
went 2020 has been the real-life
equivalent of hell-bent oh god I hope
not because that thing just got worse
and worse and worse towards the end you
need to find me in comparison where the
front half of it it has all the worst
stuff in it ever see Japanese spider-man
I I have it I know of it I know what it
is I haven't seen it if not it's
basically if Peter Parker had had the
infected blood of an alien from the
planet spider and then Uncle Ben told
him to become the Punisher yes I'm aware
of it there's also a Turkish spider-man
I think you know how I wanted certain
doctors to be in Shiro now I want Missy
to an actus
with Katra and 12 to give adora advice
about it
just lock her up in a vault ah nice
anyone else realized the uk's Korona
level chart is actually telling us the
level of spice at Nando's
thank you very much reflective rambling
I appreciate that greatly simply because
no one tells you that you are beautiful
you are valuing you are loved enough and
to pay royalties for putting that on my
work chop for one week in case someone
else needed to see it oh thank you
that was really nice do you think ace is
gay or bi the writers wanted her to be
gay but couldn't do that so they hinted
which made lots of fans think by um
either one works
I could buy either one not to mention a
mining company in Wales drilled into a
human or head lizard colony uh don't you
hate when that happens
what are your thoughts on Jem and the
Holograms I know it's a thing that
existed that is my thought really not
sure whether I'm straight or bi my mom
and sister who's gay said it'd be more
obvious later in life well I have one
clarifying moment or does it happen
gradually I mean I can't wait for
anybody else for me it's usually been a
gradual realization and then like most
of the steps in say my gender journey
and my sexuality it's not a moment of
clarity it's not a bolt out of the blue
what it is is a slow realization and
then I'm looking back and going yeah I
really should have figured this out a
heck of a lot sooner cuz all the signs
were there those wrong with me and you
know not like because I'm different but
because like you look at stuff in
hindsight it's like duh that sort of
thing that happens just finished hunters
on Amazon Amazon
it's water I promise
Amazon Prime have you watched hunters I
have not thought so on Andrew Cartmel
himself saying about the timeless child
depleted the mystery of Doctor Who
that's the funniest thing to come out of
2020 to be honest see I think he
actually has a point um I'm not sure if
I agree for my money the timeless child
makes the dog I've seen people claim
okay
timeless child have not actually really
truly talked about this in a while okay
I've seen plenty of people claim that
the timeless child brought back an air
of mystery to the doctor
I disagree fundamentally I think that
the timeless child is mystery neutral
and here is why it deleted a mystery and
replaced it with a different one so
before the mystery was we literally had
no idea whatsoever anything that ever
happened in the doctors life prior to
when we started and prior to when the
show started and he was found in that
junkyard by he and Barbara was Susan so
the mystery was fairly all-encompassing
who he was what he did I mean we know he
knew the master that's about it we don't
know really why he fled
Gallifrey why he took Susan with him
what he did in his life his place in
that society we get little hints but
like there's plenty of mystery there's
stuff that we don't know that's now gone
because now the answer is well he never
had a normal function Aiki they she
however the doctor was I was saying he
cuz in my mind I was thinking Hartnell
so that would that was by male pronouns
were in my head so they they now never
had a normal function in Time Lord
Society they were always something
special what they were and where they
came from is now the mystery but it's
wiped out
that original mystery of not knowing the
doctor's background prior to when we
started following the character in the
show so for my money its mystery neutral
you took away one and replaced it with
another which is part of why my ultimate
feeling about the timeless child at
least as of right now until we see the
show do some more with it is for me to
go what was the point I just want to
thank you for your problematic authors
video it helped me it helped put me at
ease about a project I'm working on oh
I'm glad to hear that
that turned out better than I thought it
would especially considering I didn't
script it I that made me nervous because
I remember thinking maybe this is
something I should script but it came
out all right if you like comedy I
recommend ninja sex party I feel like
I've seen some of their stuff but I
can't remember now how are you sorry if
I'm late no worries umm pretty drunk God
backing up backing up back in wow jeez
I'm so far behind
I've seen people queue for McDonald's in
the UK with camels we are a strange
country ok not even sure what to I don't
know how to parse that sentence pretty
sure I heard something about a chicken
run too well if they do it I'm pretty
sure they won't have Mel Gibson in it
I saw Last Crusade for the first time in
theaters a couple years ago in the
cinema and legit gasps that leap of
faith scene nice that's cool
I swear it every time someone mentions
the timeless Charlie your groan gets
louder and more intense that is a
distinct possibility me here's Buffy the
Vampire Slayer oh my god Daphne from the
scooby-doo movie that CGI scrimmage
oh is a vampire slayer oh good grief
tomorrow is Jodie Whitaker's birthday oh
that's nice
I wasn't trying anything to get a rise
just seemed similar I didn't know what
like I'm I'm ribbing you back it's meant
to be playful who are your favorite
LGBTQI characters in sci-fi I I know
it's a loaded question
oh geez off the top my head I AK I
honestly don't know I think I mean
probably Jack you know Jack Harkness
Inara from Firefly put her on there the
thing is I have a hard time narrowing
down a ton that are confirmed as lgbtq+
in some variety you know that aren't
simply alien races and I don't like to
count those because I'm not a huge fan
of the let's take a marginalized group
and make them allegorically alien so I
don't like to count that those are the
only took that came off without my head
somebody will probably shout in the chat
a much better idea i totes would kind of
enjoy a deconstruction approach to
Doctor Who which might turn things on
its head and create cool situations
maybe for an episode if not whole
seasons I'm very rarely where we good
I'm not drunk wary of deconstruction
within the Canon narrative of a piece
that at the end of the day is why I
think so many people took so harshly to
the last Jedi it's not that it's bad
deconstruction it's perfectly good
deconstruction but by its nature when
you deconstruct something you break it
and you take it apart and if you bother
to reassemble it at all it's not going
to be the same thing anymore and the
best deconstructionist work are usually
dealing with pastiche --is or at the
very least are out of continuity if it's
an ongoing
thing they tried to deconstruct star
wars within the primary Star Wars
franchise I think that was a mistake
not that you can't deconstruct it but
you're breaking it you're breaking it in
the thing that you are doing so like
watchman's a massive deconstruction and
alan moore wanted to do that story with
existing characters in DC wouldn't let
him because they knew that what he
planned to do would ruin those
characters and they could never use them
any other way again so they didn't let
him and he had to create his own
versions The Dark Knight Returns is a
deconstruction sent in a future so it's
separate from the continuity so it
doesn't break Batman as we know him red
Sun same thing for Superman
plus you know things like supreme and
and all sorts of things deconstruction
is best done as a pastiche of some kind
and I would actually say that the same
of Aaron Johnson Aaron John huh Ryan
Johnson's work prior to the last Jedi
because brick is a deconstruction of new
art chops Brothers Bloom is a
deconstruction of cop-con and heist
movies and looper is a deconstruction of
time-travel movies knives out is a
deconstruction of whodunit movies but
none of those had any kind of backlash
because he was deconstructing tropes as
opposed to specific characters that
people know in love see what I mean I
might have to give up trying to catch up
because I keep giving these long-winded
answers been back and working at KFC for
a while now but we only accept carbs and
people give us grief let me only have
cash who doesn't carry cards in this
crisis I like to almost never have cash
if I had cash is because somebody handed
me cash it's like after burlesque shows
I have cash basically you know lots of
singles few fives there was a short
release recently world where Bill and
nardole send letters to each other
that was pretty nice III need to catch
up on the doctor who locked down channel
I've seen some of it I really need to
watch the rest of it and like do a video
on it quite an outsider to Doctor Who
but I kind of think they might go for an
all just a dream plot twist actively
eating Moffat Sarah out of Cannon I
can't imagine anyone will be stupid
enough to think of that or a green light
it because the the nature of Doctor Who
you do there's no need to wreak on out
what previous showrunners have done
because just ignore it and move forward
and do your own thing I don't want
anybody's time running Doctor Who to be
spent tying up the previous person's
mess just ignore to move forward forget
how bad I think the u.s. specifically
might be headed for no-man's land
if only we had an actual Batman yeah was
wondering if a debate style that
appealed to you at all at the moment I
thought the vid with crispy was really
cool and there's not exactly a shortage
of issues to debate right now um within
very specific parameters so like
something like what I did with crispy
which was a very fan centric debate
about you know the about the product and
it wasn't a debate about the fandom it
wasn't a debate about you know future
directions for the show okay well you
put it this way I have absolutely there
there are people there are youtubers who
have very diametrically opposed views to
me on a lot of things be they Doctor Who
or be they very existence of somebody
like me and people who have those
harshly divided you know have drawn a
line in the sand and shout about anyone
who disagrees with them style youtubers
who are
on the other side of these issues I have
absolutely no interest in debating
because I see no good that comes out of
that I'd be more than happy to have
conversations with any number of them
off mic not recorded no audience but not
debate videos no I just watched the
snowmen my god do i ship Jenny and
vastra they're cute aren't they
grandson what did you do during the
coronavirus grandad what did you do
during the common virus grandad were you
in a central worker me to be honest kid
I was drunk for most of it that's
essential that's been essential to get
through this that's how ADHD was for me
kind of like David done and I'm
breakable looking back on everything and
being like holy crap how did I miss that
problem is sexuality is never diagnosed
well not professionally
anyways sexuality is a self diagnosed
condition I'm by a news commander was my
sexuality catalyst back in 2017 and then
I watched stuff like Captain America
movies and 11 doctor stories and then it
clicked I was like yeah it's kind of
funny isn't it
Vera its water I swear me behind my
keyboard you bloody liar why don't you
trust me okay I think I am gonna have to
joy I need to jump down to the bottom
and give up trying to catch up through
these questions cuz I I have failed I
need to accept that I have failed at
this I got a back up real quick I think
yes I caught all the super chats alright
so if somebody asked a question that I
missed I'm sorry I need to jump down to
the bottom because where we're now in
the last 10 minutes or so and and I I'm
not gonna catch up
I really like the timeless child but I
feel like Chibnall should have just said
the timeless child was Rassilon because
he actually had infinite regenerations
totes confused me yeah I I can't right
now
I blame basil Baker Street for making me
a gay furry we'll see you should you
should really be blaming Ratigan cuz he
was totally Basil's daddy oh yeah are
you bilingual nope I can barely speak
English
water wate R whatever alcohol is tasty
and eases the ranting oh you cracked my
code shoot Vera don't you trust me me
refined beat files a restraining order
ha
possibly the smart thing to do let's be
honest six doctor is a total sex symbol
that noble brow made me curve away from
women okay I need to I need to jump over
to the the discord real quick so I'll be
right back hold your questions I'll be
back okay and usual plug reminder
discord that council geeks discord does
exist it is a patreon supporter
exclusive perk so if you support me on
patreon at $2 or more you get access to
the discord yeah we come join the fun
let's see um good job in the latest you
bag full coop thank you
any news on when the sequel corona shark
vs. octo virus is coming out November
not a question but I think we need
nothing less than Pride Month in a time
like this you might say well why not
Black History Month well that would be
good too but with Pride Month we show
that everyone of any race color creed
and other sexual orientation is free to
love each other I think we need more
these days the more inclusion wall
I do agree but like I said part of my
hesitation on doing a pride theme is I
don't want it to I I don't want it
anyway to seem like I'm coming across as
basically celebrating myself when so
much crap is going on and I hope I
haven't done that to atrociously but you
don't have to point out that I have a
big eel I know I have a big ego
but I'm trying I'm trying not to make
too many things about me even though
that's what my brain usually wants me to
do I've learnt that a convention learnt
I love that you wrote learned I've
learned that a convention I usually go
to each year is reviewing whether or not
they should allow police themed cosplay
I understand why given the current
circumstance but seeing as costumes like
samurai military are allowed I do wonder
if this is a little blinkered any
thoughts on this well so the thing is
you need to understand that the issue of
police and police imagery is actually
pretty specific to the police it's I
don't feel that it would be hypocritical
if that's your question because the
issues right now and this is not to say
there are not issues with other
authority figures like military or
samurai ongoing concern I don't think so
but like but you know like military or
government officials or whatever is
because the issues trying to be
addressed right now are very specific to
the relationship between the police and
the members of the black population in
this country so it is very specific to
the police now the problems don't begin
and end with the police there's a lot of
systemic stuff there's a lot of stuff at
all levels that me
it's work it needs to be addressed
but the police is the very specific
thing that is being highlighted and and
sort of drilled into and expositor Don
right now so I don't I get why they
would consider doing that and I don't
it's one of those situations where I
would feel bad for the organizers of the
convention because you they're in a
situation where either they allow that
kind of cosplay and run the risk of
confrontations on the floor because
intentional or not someone choosing to
dress as a cop with everything going on
is going to be taken by some people as a
show of support for police at a time
when you know saying I support the cops
means something different than it
historically has and at the same time
for them to not have it suddenly becomes
a political statement even if their only
intention is to minimize any chance of
confrontation on the floor so I don't
envy them having to make that call
what nothing you're not a trump Finn I
don't know how many are really left at
our fans oh there's some I've got
relatives and co-workers yeah also are
you looking to watch the five Bloods I
think it was a great movie it was pretty
graphic at times I'm debating that I
feel like I shouldn't I would like to I
don't know I don't know if I'm in the
headspace to be able to digest it so I I
don't know I would I would like to watch
it I would like to be in a space where
I'm okay to watch it
let's see so I'm back now in the main
chat what are you thoughts on Steven
Spielberg's hook it's not a good movie
but I'm a nostalgic for it torn between
using super chests to check if you've
had a chance to read my work and not
wanting to create a system where you're
incentivized not to oh I need I need to
go back and sort through my email cuz
yours is not the only you're not the
only person who I said I would take a
look at that work I haven't I have a
comic book sitting over there I've got a
novel in the library that was sent to me
you know that they that you people these
are your works that you are sharing with
me and I want to take them in but I'm
not I I have a hard time being on top of
my own stuff you know the stuff that I
I'm already planning on doing and trying
to work up a stuff into it I'm I wish I
was better at this I do and yeah I'm
sorry I will
how do people try and get to that I'm so
sorry
where did I where was I doctor who has
apparently had deconstruction of stories
but no one but one example was hell-bent
supposedly out oh hey I want to see
someone make the argument that hell-bent
was deconstructionist cuz I've also seen
midnight and human nature described as
deconstructions I'm not sure about human
nature midnight quite possibly because
it does deconstruct and take away the
things that we take for granted about
the doctor in these situations where
he's always able to talk his way out of
it and and he convinces everyone that
he's the good guy
so I I'll by midnight as a
deconstructionist Doctor Who piece but I
think what's key about why that works is
it deconstructs the scenarios that the
show Doctor Who usually gives us it's
not deconstructing the character and
pulling him apart it's polar
how well things tend to go for him it's
pulling the circumstances apart so if
you can properly sharpen the blade of
deconstruction so you're not just
cutting a swath across the entire thing
yeah you could probably get some decent
stuck out it it's starting stuff oh my
god I wish I was drunk and I could
explain why I can't talk haha
would you ever make a cocktail of
putting Bertie Botts every flavor beans
and alcohol in her life how much would
you charge to take a shot make me an
offer
there's a transgender companion being
introducing the new 8th doctor audio
played by Rebecca root who played the
doctor not that one in last Christmas oh
that's cool
thank you very much jack I appreciate
that hope this doesn't sound turfy but
I'm always confused when people say they
felt trans how do I know what being sis
mail is supposed to feel like when I
haven't experienced anything else in my
life well it's really difficult to
explain and it's a big part of what I'm
about to go off for a while again guys
so if you post more questions while I'm
talking about this I'm gonna miss them
so this is part of why so many people
whether they themselves be trans in some
flavor or not they tend to latch on to
the idea of dysphoria because for many
trans people dysphoria is the guideline
because they feel wrong in their body
and that's still difficult to explain
how that feels but if you've ever had
that sort of creeping no
this isn't right something isn't right
whether it be because you're in a place
you haven't been before and just feel
uncomfortable or you're you've been
stuck at a job for a while we were like
this is crushing my soul that kind of
feeling I kind of constant wait on you
but about your body about your gender
that's kind of what dysphoria is and
it's why so many trans people sort of
point to dysphoria as a reason for
transition I did a whole video talking
about this on on the veer a while
channel but I don't have dysphoria not
pronounced as for yet head anyway to
whatever extent I experienced that at
all it's incredibly mild but that's also
why I didn't even consider transitioning
in any way shape or form
and until my mid-30s because I didn't
have a clear direction and most people
who say they felt they felt trans or
they if they were born male they feel
like a woman or if they were you know
trans men born female they feel like a
man most of the time they're talking
about it was wrong where I was and that
everything about that felt wrong now I'm
hearing it feels right for me it's been
much more round about much less I'm
wrong where I am I have to find
something else and more like I'm okay
where I am but I feel like I can feel
better about myself but it is really
hard and that there is for me
interacting with me at least there's no
shame in saying I don't understand
because if you have never experienced
doubt or questioning yourself about your
gender it's really hard for people who
have experienced that to explain what it
feels like because if you are
male you were born male and you just are
it's not anything that you felt male you
just are like everything about this is
fine
you don't you've never even had to
examine how you feel about your gender
cuz you you haven't had a reason to
that's not a criticism I'm not saying
like you haven't thought about this have
you like you you had no need to you had
no reason there was no reason or impetus
for you to think about how it felt to be
male because it was no other way they
you ever would have thought to be so the
fact that it's difficult for you to
relate to that is understandable and
it's it's one of the big hurdles for
trans people trying to sort of
communicate our experience to cisgender
people and it's kind of the barriers of
language and you have to just kind of
dip into your you know whatever well of
empathy you have available and I kind of
default to one of my favorite lines from
my favorite Star Wars movie which is the
fourth one
Star Wars for the I'm sorry not Star
Wars Star Trek start oh my god
it's not boos Star Trek for the voyage
home and this is after cuz Spock died in
Star Trek 2 spoilers I came back to life
in Star Trek 3 spoilers and in the
fourth one he's talking with dr. McCoy
and dr. McCoy tries to ask him what that
was like and what Spock says to him is
it will be impossible to discuss the
topic without a common frame of
reference there's this pause and McCoy
goes you mean I have to die to discuss
your insight on death but Spock's got a
right the experience that he had was so
unique and so divorced from anything
that he could relate it to that he
really can't talk about it with McCoy
and I kind of feel like tribe explains
what it feels like to be trans to
someone
this is a little bit that thing too but
we also have to try and overcome it
because we all have to live together and
trying to come to a better understanding
is only a good thing thank you for
responding I understand it's taking you
time bang thank you for understanding
um I random hooby and hereby decree have
the title of precious bean to be R Us /
Nathaniel - bye everyone here in the
chat right now oh thank you did you
stopped uploading Let's Plays because
they didn't get as many views because
you told us you hate Trump and you can
to have heated gamer moments where you
yell out slurs haha I I need I need not
even I want I need I need to finish
newfound courage and I will finish that
as a let's play the reason they stopped
showing up on this channel was yes they
got incredibly low views they I moved
those videos to the break room and it
was my intention to finish that game and
consider doing some others but like
again ah no it's been a tough two days
someone who I really cared about and was
my main person to talk to and Quarantine
blocked me and goes to me and you're
here to cheer me up thanks I'm I'm glad
I can help and I also understand I'm not
going to get into specifics about any of
this because it's not only my story to
tell and I don't want to cause drama but
just understand that I I understand the
feeling of somebody who you care about
deciding to digitally at least cut you
out of their lives in recent times I get
it it's not fun
and they can wear on you you're such an
inspiration of bright light in this
crazy time oh thank god people are so
dang sweet fear or should I put that on
the to-do list
yeah go ahead Caroline add it on there
it's it's a long list I'm sure it is
Carolyn gives me a line on a lot of
stuff she's very good at keeping track
of things I'm still waiting for a Helena
bonham-carter to make an appearance on
Doctor Who I would watch that Riley
wrote an article do you want me to send
you a link yes please miss that so
that's the other on top of everything
else double of all the stuff that I'm
trying to watch the games I want to play
the videos I want to make like I can't
keep up with people's social media I
miss so much it's nuts
fun fact the Supergirl TV show had the
first ever live-action transgender
superhero yes I've seen that Karen cuz I
started sees them for I skipped the
second half of season 3 it really wasn't
working for me I started season 4 I need
to go back on that and pick it up again
let's see apparently the hybrid
deconstructs lore arcs like the timeless
child instead of giving us lore about
the doctor's origins they did a metaphor
instead metaphors never heard of those
see the thing is I need gilliam on
today's I actually need to re-watch hell
bent to decide if that reading has any
merit appreciate your videos on Doctor
Who and religion but as a religious
person I can't imagine how I could
respect religious traditions if I was
born atheists
what gave you this respect being raised
by somebody who taught me that she
didn't know I didn't know nobody knows
some people think they know and have
their own beliefs and they have a right
to them they have a right to not be
treated badly because of them
now it's always in my approach to
religion I don't know it's not booze
they say if their speech is getting
worse and worse as they drink more oh
yeah boy
it kind of is isn't it I feel like I'm
drinking more yeah I'm just doing it to
like clear my throat as if that's the
problem as if I'm like no I'm just
saying Zee stupidity interesting story
for my drama exam I did a bullet
I did a bleh oh my god I feel like I
should be drinking I'd probably be more
articulate I did a play called things I
know to be true there's a trans
character in it and my friend who played
him came out as gender-fluid after oh ah
I it wasn't in a play was just in a
scene in college I did a scene from
Angels in America which is a play I
don't love to be honest but I played a
drag queen in that and theater gives you
the opportunity to try on some different
hats in in a controlled environment and
that can be helpful anyone here think
the woman in resolution who said unit
was gone kind of looked like James
Charles I don't know who that is so I
have no opinion Mike at me out after you
laughter I assume he said hello well
hello to the kitty favorite Mel Brooks
movie if they exist I nostalgically
Spaceballs happy Pride Month uh was it
either your stream or Alton Brown's live
stream I didn't know what to watch both
good choices oh I'm flattered to even be
considered as an option versus that
people are saying really sweet things
about you so I'll give it a go you're
okay what do you want for me I'm British
cheers me who would you cast in the
wicked movie I have no idea I just think
they need to not make that thoughts on
the Supreme Court ruling about lgbtq+
discrimination being a civil rights
issue and rectifying it I mean I talked
about at the start of the stream it's
such an important ruling it's incredibly
important foundation but we need to now
build on that foundation because there's
a lot of other stuff to do and obviously
there's a lot of other issues going on
as well am I the only one who always
stays up at night thinking about how Ben
McKenzie looks like gene Wilder I'm now
picturing the red carpet scene and Willy
Wonka Willy Wonka I I don't know if
you're the only one I'm not one of those
people so I think I'm almost caught up
ah I'm probably miss remembering the
argument about hell-bent if you're
curious I can link the blog they showed
sure if you want to know promises that
I'll read it if they see the color of
your water just tell them it's from
fritz from a canal cheeky fun fact and
mr. Holmes when he goes to see the movie
the actor who played him on screen is
the same actor who played young Sherlock
Holmes back in 1985 oh wow I didn't
realize that ah I guess I totes have new
perspectives writing LGBTQ characters
now though I totes created them before I
knew I was LGBTQ it's it's funny like as
you evolved to go back and look at if
you're if you're a creative type person
to go back and look at your earlier work
and realize oh god there's there's war
signs I should have picked up on or
you've realized oh god I was really
trying to not be what I am when I wrote
this can go either way
this vine thumbs up 20/20 dad it's the
good cush
it's the dollar store how good could it
Behe I actually love you as saying mate
I'm from York Shire when replying to
Graham as a Yorkshire man my
I completely get it okay here's a pitch
Willy Wonka chocolate factory plus
Doctor Who equals money ha ha ha have
you ever watched a movie frequency I've
seen about half of it I think it's one
of those things that was like on on TV
like back when I had normal TV coming
into my house and I like all part of it
but okay I really do need to wrap it up
I'm the same for not noticing how
depressed stories I used to write sound
I'm glad my stuff is more optimistic now
that is nice okay that reminds me of a
story I wrote when I was 12 where the
main character was super gay and I just
didn't realize Douglas Adams in a Doctor
Who episode who so it's funny I was a
couple years ago that I realized this
that virtually every piece of fiction I
have ever written very like almost none
of which is viewable or published but
every short story short play the
full-length play the novel that I'm
trying to wrap up nearly everything is
about people in transition not like
gender transition but like the world or
people either shifting from one state of
being to another or caught in the middle
between the two normally defined things
every single piece I've ever wrote with
one exception that I can think of all
the tell my head every other piece that
I've ever written is about that thumb
Attica Lee I realized that a couple
years ago I'm like son of oak all right
I am gonna wrap it up there I want to
thank everybody for joining me on this
one one day deep in the future I'll pay
you to review Ballad of Buster shrugs
and Power Rangers rpm whoo oh I hope I
live to see that day
um thanks for everybody who joined me
this this this went well I it's it's
it's been a kind of day so this was this
was nice it was nice way to wrap things
up well thank you randomness as always
feel five-by-five laughed hard run fast
be kind and remember take it sleazy so
thank you everybody
thank you for my mods for keeping
everything clean and the chats and thank
you to everyone who contributed to
everyone who was just here who listened
just thank you and I hope you are well
happy pride be safe out there and please
remember that you are beautiful you are
valid and you are loved you are the
council I just run the meetings have a
good night guys
people I still say guys and my head is
gender-neutral
still working on that years late